it has been a [ __ ] millennia since we
all caught up with you
it's been quite a while uh well over two
years
between us well over three years between
us and never
yeah i think i mean it was the first
time for you well i met you very very
briefly but you don't
but you are cosplaying as like chun li i
think oh yeah that sounds about right
you were like i was like oh hi cause i
was with jerry and then you was the
first time i met you right
no that was um two years after no one
knows
we met in 2016. was it really yeah
after we met um then we like randomly
shot in japan and i was like i need to
go buy a bunch of eroget
and we were like yeah let's make a video
oh yeah yeah we spent like six hours in
that one irrigate shop
i think i remember watching it i
remember that video i made like an
animated vlog about that because it was
too messed up yeah because
otherwise it would have just been
censored for 15 minutes i did that
i just had like mosaics the whole time
like for seven minutes straight it's
just like us talking in mosaics and then
like cutting really well i mean it's
like being on a
zoom call in public now with the filter
behind you it's like hi everyone here's
the video just everything is because i
remember watching that video
i remember thinking it looks like you
know one of those undercover cop videos
when i'm like
where they like bust like like the
pedophile or something
just you just like sneakily like going
around the shop and you're like
so before we jump right into the deep
end of content i think reyna you should
probably introduce yourself to the
audience who might not know who you are
yes um i don't really know what i do
anymore because
due to the pandemic i had to like really
kind of do different things that i
normally do but
i do do youtube i'm normally a host for
other channels like first we feast i
have a
show called gochi gang where oh wow
right i totally you've literally like
done everything i swear like that yeah
i always saw he's like a youtube jack of
all trades you were like always
you were like always everywhere always
hosting something
no big serum i'm gonna cry
i'm filled with emotions this is also
the first time i've like collaborated
physically with
another person in a whole year so like
even like physical contact
with another person is kind of intense
for me oh my god it's real
it's real and we're speaking english but
um but yeah normally i'm a host and then
i also do some voice work i
obviously do youtube but for now it's
really just to kind of keep myself
as relevant as possible until my hosting
gigs come back
right yeah because most of your hostings
are overseas yeah they're overseas
and also even like voicing stuff i
recently just uh
did a couple japanese voices for
some video game companies here but i had
to record myself
alone in my home and like i don't have
anything yeah like i had to use my own
mixer and i was so scared so
even like i don't even go to studios
anymore so again this is very exciting
i'm honored thank you well i mean like
i guess like how i found you and i think
how a lot of people also know you is
back in the day
you're on sauce fan yes okay yeah that
is definitely that's what i mean
literally reina has done everything like
rayna has been around forever doing
we forgot that's how i discovered it
you're like royalty yeah there's
actually an ongoing joke about
42. i actually came on this podcast
specifically
to destroy the rumors yes that's what i
came to destroy people with
facts and lodges yes and i have to throw
you under the bus um
last night yeah yeah yeah two years ago
when we were doing the hanami thing yeah
um
in one of the videos you loudly and
jokingly were like no she's really 42
everybody
and everyone believed you
you had like the silliest look and you
were just like running around just like
yelling and yet they all believed you
they want they want the truth more you
know
it bothers me so much like as i get
older and as i
like approach that age and that like
curve gets closer
it'll be right eventually right you know
a broken clock is right two times a day
right
people watch that video next year and
being like well she's actually 42 now so
no but yeah but like i feel you're one
of those like youtube personalities
where it's kind of like
everyone knows who you are but there
isn't like a specific moment in time
where
people came to know you it was you're
one of those personalities where it's
like
i mean if you're watching she's hosting
everything in my life
it's the kind of name of phase where
it's like yeah i've definitely seen you
somewhere
but i can't pinpoint one right i can't
place it i get that a lot yeah you've
been to you've been involved in so many
different projects and so many different
channels
as like the professional host that if
anyone's in like the nerd industry
especially the anime industry
they've definitely seen your face around
oh yeah yeah i worked really hard in the
beginning so to establish myself
at sourcefed they obviously wanted they
were you know
ramping up to gain other hosts and i was
their third generation host and they
definitely wanted to get into anime and
before that i was translating anime for
fan subs and for crunchyroll so i was
like i made sure i secured that
professional angle so that i have like
something to talk about
exactly it's not just like oh like i i
promise i know what i'm talking about
it's like no i know the technical stuff
so i can kind of
delve into really strange things if i
need to or things like people don't
really reveal normally so
so so source said was like the first big
thing yeah i would say so
how did you get involved with that yeah
and i'm also curious because i'm sure
the view is gonna be the same way
i know i've heard sourcefed i know that
all i know is that philip defranco was
jumping right into it back then with
that
um i don't i don't really
i i get sued by phil
i i don't know fully what sourcefed is
so maybe explain to the audience while
you know what it is and how it became a
thing sure so
sourcefed was pretty i'd say like og
youtube where they started with this
thing called 20 minutes or less and
they'd have these really quick
short segments where they would delve
into news but make it really comedic
because the original
og-3 were comedians and they were very
intellectual too so they knew how to
mold the story into a very digestible
but also like a funny way so they were
really good at selecting stories
yeah and they obviously purposefully did
not choose like intense or like
depressing things and uh they really
made a name for themselves they left
that's a depressing [ __ ] to philly d
right
at least like like he has a lot a little
bit of a long-form
platform where he's able to talk about
it so it's not like dismissing it
so but yeah um and i think they were
part of the original
youtube uh startup program where i think
phil was given startup money from
youtube to start up
sourcefed and that's how he yeah and
that's how he kind of ragtag
handled that and hired the three this is
when the partnership program was just
like really early days right yeah and
very exclusive where people were just
like oh you can make
money from being a youtuber what is
going
on this is like 2009 2010
maybe yeah yeah because i was an intern
in 2012
actually that's how they found me i
moved to
la for fun and also i was like sick of
the snow in new jersey that's where i
grew up
and i auditioned for well no i didn't
audition i
got hired as one of their interns and i
was like i was phil's intern as well
and he had me guest host
he had me guest host a sexy ladies
segment
i don't remember when people didn't
really use for the thumbnails right
it's like that was the first time i was
ever on camera
[Music]
how did this pitch come about he's like
listen right i got a job that only you
can do
sexy i don't want to apply for this no i
was just his
intern i was like getting him lunches
and coffee and i was like
and i was just doing some uh like
research for metadata kind of thing
was it a thing where i i don't want this
to seem too misogynistic could you like
spice it up a little bit maybe that was
actually exactly it
okay okay how exact that was okay
i know you phil yo yo ashley do you want
to host a new segment for us
and it literally like the segment was
called
intern reina brings in the sexy lady
you can't make this [ __ ] up so
that happened that's probably a past
that phil kind of wants to like brush
under the rug right
that is the most 2012 sounding title
i've ever heard so that's when phil
started jumping right into it
i had to say sup nation that's why i
like rings in my head
but it was actually a lot of fun and um
darren
uh was the cameraman at the time and he
was the producer and
he was so good and he was like so
professional and he
really i don't know he like brought me
into this new world of being
not an intern but talking on camera and
i was so nervous but
it was just like so much fun and also i
was talking about sexy ladies which i
was like
yeah i'll do that we could be talking
about worse things yeah
the worst part about it though was that
it was this new
fresh 18 girl who was being like
who was being i guess i googled before
that but she like just turned 18 so it's
like
it's legal now and i have to like do
that
yeah so youtube 10 years ago was a
different planet
yeah and that was like monetized yeah i
really
can only imagine it makes me feel sad
that when you refer to sourcefed you're
like oh it's an og youtube channel and
i'm just like
oh [ __ ] i guess it is isn't it oh [ __ ]
you're you're an og youtube channel
because like i've been
following phil since like since like
close to when he started right
so i remember when he announced
sourcefed i was like oh what's this
what's this new venture that he's doing
this sounds exciting
and now that it's like now an og dead
channel that
is just buried in people's memories like
that that makes me feel a bit sad
i'm just having this realization live on
camera i i used to watch sourcefed a lot
oh my god my [ __ ] like yeah i used to
watch it
a lot i was like at one point i would
say it's probably one of my favorite
channels to watch wow
just because it's like again it's like
you know it wasn't like as
you know i watched philly days as well
obviously the new stuff but it was also
just like
you know it was edutainment yes right
that's yes that's that was like the big
selling point for you i was like you get
to learn some [ __ ] but at the same time
you can have fun with these comedians
yeah yeah and it kind of you kind of
remember it because it's funny
i think that was also the other point of
it like it's shareable because it's not
dark and it's also funny so it makes
sense to like put all over facebook kind
of thing everybody else can watch it and
be entertained by it so
yeah it was like a brilliant idea and
they started making other sub channels
like sourcefed nerd
and then i ran their gaming channel
super panic frenzy with steven septic
and that was like my golden time i'd say
like that was when i was already finally
comfortable being on camera it was right
right and then i left for crunchyroll
so so what made you leave
um i was really heartbroken
that they cancelled super panic frenzy
because on my gaming channel because
we were hitting all the numbers like
hard we were completely setting all the
goals and
um at the time we were owned by
discovery digital networks
and yeah and i remember that i i
remember sourcefed ending and then they
tried to continue it under a different
name yeah something right yeah that was
bad that was
um i think it's like a completely
different company now but right when
sourcefed
like when discovery let go of sourcefed
somebody tried to pick it up and kind of
like almost
zombie reanimated yeah yeah yeah
audience and usurping it yeah like
they took the same channel renamed it
and hired different hosts
to uh continue on this show as though
yeah yeah it was it felt very like
puppeted and straight it kind of felt
like you went to a friend's house and
there was just a stranger sitting there
pretending to be your friend who's my
house now wait a minute what what's
going on
i'm at connor's house welcome back
good to see you back here it was like oh
that's not connor that's a connor
animatronic
that's so worried oh my god